foreign
Scott's with us in Milwaukee Wisconsin
hey Scott
hey uh Dave and John thank you thank you
for taking my call sure how can we help
so I'm on uh babysat baby step two uh I
have 136
000 in student loans
um and was wondering if using the equity
I have in my house to in about four or
five years down the road uh either
refinance or take out a HELOC uh to pay
off that student loans when uh it
becomes an option
well I you didn't pay off the student
loan you just moved it on to your home
if you don't pay a student loan they
don't even knock that around yeah if
they don't if they don't uh if you don't
pay a student loan they don't foreclose
on your house or if you don't pay a
HELOC they foreclosed on your house
you just increase your risk
you just put your house on the line for
your stupid student loan no thank you
sure even like refinancing to uh to a
15-year again you just you just put your
house on the line for the student loan
you didn't pay it off dude you just
moved it you understand right yep and
you pay it off means that you don't owe
it anymore anywhere you moved it with
more risk yeah yeah so what's your
household income
uh about a hundred cool good for you how
old are you
uh 33 and four kids good for you she
stay at home mom full-time or what
uh no she works part-time so what's your
total household income
a hundred oh with a hundred includes her
okay
how old are the kiddos
uh one for
11 and 12. what do you do for a living
a physical therapist
good for you you paid a lot for that if
that whole if that's if that's true
that's all you want you got here you got
hammered okay um
most pts I know are making more than
eighty thousand dollars a year what's is
it your Market what's it just started uh
just started okay I bet didn't you
yeah so base salary of about uh 70 uh
when you start and I work I work
weekends when did you when did you get
out when did you get your PT
2018 so about three and a half years now
yeah okay yeah you're gonna you're but
John's right you're gonna you should see
ten thousand dollar bumps along the way
here pretty quick as you get some
experience and you got the ability to
add some hours except for the fact you
got a bunch of Littles at home but the
uh uh yeah tear into this thing I want
you to just get just roll up your
sleeves and go bust your butt stay out
of restaurants no vacations and get this
thing knocked out and then when your
house is paid off it's paid off you
didn't have those big butt student loan
over there hiding behind your mortgage
acting like it didn't happen it's a form
of financial denial uh so no I I and I'm
gonna help you Scott I've been right
where you are and didn't know what to do
it's we've got the answer it's called
Financial Peace University
and if y'all hang on I'm gonna pay for
it for you and your wife and your four
littles and I want you to go through
this class it's nine lessons and we're
gonna Jack you up Jazz you up and teach
you what to do and if you'll go do
exactly what we teach you should have
this paid off in about three years